já foi assim
bom é conforme a pouco não vou falar
sobre nada do que o cloud isso eu não
vou falar sobre design gráfico é vou
falar só uma experiência do ano passado
em 2016 em que em 2007 foi um ano
bastante intenso e que não sabe
precisamente porque é por este desafio
que foi a travessia entre o pico faial
já foi ao pico é em que é que o que é
fantástico e que o produto que começar é
um lado nós estamos agora toda a gente
já esperava se um seguramente está
acontecendo essa imensa jogos orgulho o
docs natação e facilmente consegue
perceber que o som 5 1 é termos uma
noção distorcida do som mas as imagens
são brutalmente nítida souza já que nós
vemos através dos óculos é algo
fantástico incrível quase de escrever e
este esta passagem porque é remetem
também para uma experiência com a
fantasia do ano passado que era essa
travessia são cerca de 60 quilômetros em
que 268 quilômetros nós andamos lá não
me permite enfim mais ou menos à deriva
no meio do canal e temos tempo para
pensar em muita coisa
em uma delas uma dessas coisas este é o
tema da história que me traz aqui foi
com o facto de o ano passado os meus
filhos precisar de uma do transplante em
importante dentro da água em agosto e em
agosto eu já estava com essa história na
cabeça que era um filho vai ficar um
tanto quanto e neste momento nesse curso
de alguém que fez um transplante
o filho poderia ser outra pessoa
qualquer mas só cair um filho
ficamos apreensivos o choque o que eu
vou fazer como é que o que vai ocorrer
daqui o que vai decorrer deste processo
até aqui tudo bem até que chega é
importante em agosto anuncia atuar no
tempo em agosto já estava no processo eo
próprio
de ser um doador potencial da zona sul
do rio
e quando nós entramos neste processo do
rim é logo à partida um conjunto de
situações que temos só um estranho ou
seja que surgem essas incertezas não
sabemos muitas coisas e é é que foi o
primeiro momento é isso recorda 1 e
quase com esta passagem não recordo sons
é falar com os médicos não me recordo
uma coisa ou distorcida mas recordam das
imagens das imagens do consultório e é
no dia em que o conjunto dos anos
o médico diz que é compatível com essa
o rio é compatível importantes o moço
logicamente a receita é competitiva e
recordam dessa imagem é com sosa lo a um
deve imaginar não é dependente temos
essa notícia que não maio é uma
circunstância ano mas será mais adversas
gostaram mais o oceano
sou compatível a funcionar dois acordam
de quando pensamos num consenso não sei
se alguém já passou por esse processo
mas quando é perceber como é que as
coisas funcionam
salvaguardando dizendo que no momento em
simultâneo quando estava há seis anos
rodrigo entrou na estatística de espera
está aqui é porque são quase duas horas
da manhã
é mas era hora é porque o protocolo
também assim não seja só para
contextualizar discreto muito falar
rápido mais mas quando existe uma lista
ativa
geralmente é que o que é o problema é
para o hospital
ocorre em volta do himalaia madrugada no
meio dos olhos e esta é a hora em que
mim mais gostar vá acontecer
jobs noite e dormir e todos os dias em
setembro ou outubro o transplante foi em
dezembro a fazer o mesmo na altura em
que o quando ia dormir
sep o fundo vai tocar essa fofa não vai
tocar o fórum ocorre um dia após dia só
que este ano até que se conformar com o
que tinha dito temos a notícia
o rio é compatível
a partir desse momento é uma coisa
estranha muito estranha
fiquei com algo completamente diferente
no comportamento de repente você ter um
mórmon ou ruim que era coisa mais
valiosa do mundo
guerra algo que nem é que usava todos os
dias e dizia stream segundo filho e
aquelas tarefas diárias na rua na carro
atravessar uma rua atrás a uma
passadeira tornavam as coisas por vezes
não direi aos ivo
mas será que vai acontecer alguma coisa
será que será que estão aqui
este processo foi uma coisa que foi
durante algum tempo processos produtivos
que já diz e faz tem esse trabalho é
porque porque enquanto andava neste
processo não sabia ainda não tenho uma
data da cirurgia de tratamento da
cirurgia
tanto e tudo isto a comdec imaginar aqui
uma noção estranhas de
aqui vai acontecer olhar o puto é de 160
preparar o caso rodrigo assim dentro do
possível é é até que está agora também
terá um susto
é é é da guiné do do movimento em todo
este processo ao que é fantástico é
percebermos que ok é só ter um elemento
importante é é a que faz com que as
coisas corram mãe num determinado
momento mas é estranho que nós estamos
no meio do processo isto é um processo
que se arrastou de uns quatro meses
algum tempo
nós começamos a pensar noite tudo isto e
voltando agora a imagem do canal
eu gosto da água tanto gosta de esportes
aquáticos da água e aquela sensação de
mergulhar e porque eu comecei com com
água
aquela sensação de mergulhar ele entrar
num momento água é das coisas mais
fabulosas e foi das coisas que mais me
ajudou a superar neste dia a dia
não é porque em paralelo com isso eu
tenho mais dois filhos de 13 e
distribuir a mesma atenção por tutti não
é um ou de outro estúdio profissional
mesmo ser perfeita
portanto vamos à conclusão de que houve
nesse caso é que o que era fantástica a
tentar entrar água e daí aquela ideia
que ele está mas também em todo este
processo
o tempo vai passando quando a cirurgia
agendada dezembro
se o natal portanto foi 27 de dezembro e
como devem imaginar há uma coisa que nós
a gente saiu de natal natal família uma
coisa é a lei do clima estranho porque
sabemos que estamos ali sabemos que
vamos ter uma cirurgia e sabemos que não
podemos comer muitas relacionadas com
obras estava a dizer
e tudo isto influencia a obviamente é
que o que entrada num ciclo diferente
expirar fundo foi algo que eu fiz muitas
vezes na travessia do canal
aquela coisa respirar fundo solar
deixarmos aproveite também por muitas
vezes nestas coisas é o faz mais sentido
e 11 tranquilamente pela frente
não adianta lutar contra a corrente
agora estas situações são sempre 108
quilômetros da prova
eu fiquei alguns sentimentos da ilha
outro lado é assim um brinde frente não
é chegar nas ars sete quilômetros e
ultimamente não não dá para chegar lá e
por quê porque entretanto as condições
marítimas é fazer uma corrente com cerca
de sete nós que eu vou usava para longe
daquilo que é o porto sendo bom
aquela coisa que faço é que não faço
justiça e provar que é possível sair
qualquer pessoa que não tenha de provar
nada a ninguém e tal e qual como aqui
neste processo não haver nada a provar
apenas ao importante e é isaías sempre
presente entrar na água chegou de
transplantes ou melhor o dia após o
natal portanto 26 de dezembro eo dia é
em que as meninas só que no hospital de
agora também que uma uma questão que é
importante tanto rodrigo menor estava no
local eo maior eu fui para outro carro
portanto santo antônio
me recordo é lançado com um calor
intenso na altura do natal e rodrigo é e
fui a pé para um percurso curioso que
encontrei um amigo meu é que foi a casa
quando fiquei de pé e é do porto é
encontrei na rua e fez uma coisa está
indo foi uma coisa simpática noite
oitavo games no país já estava no
hospital
assim olha vou ver o meu filho é
importante sim ao look de repente
ficamos bom é um ponto importante também
eu acho que isto é que a prime é é a
mensagem mais importante o que mais mais
me importa salvar e foi o motivo pelo
qual eu também essa história aqui que é
justificar que o que a pessoa do douro
ou seja quem dá a e ao causar dúvidas e
incertezas suas paleteiras saiu é coisa
mais simples do mundo é muito mais
simples do que o canal por meio a um
momento importante que entra no hospital
no caso da dor fez uma série de exames
para aferir se efetivamente o torcedor
logo entrou no hospital com o seu pé
pacífico ea pressão o corpo humano é uma
máquina era sensacional primeiro turno
se recuperar de uma forma muito rápida
em três dias
ao fim de três dias já estava a sair do
hospital e sai do hospital o meu pé com
a cair mais uns dos corpos é mas é algo
muito simples muito fácil para quem
recebe
obviamente que o processo é um pouco
mais complexo que mais e mais demorada
agora quanto vai com o descaso com o
rodrigo
a taxa de sucesso é eu acho que é
importante e em todo este processo está
passando rápido poder ficar aqui muito
mais tempo e com mais calma falar mas em
todo este processo
a idéia é infinito eu acho também que é
uma idéia melhor o envelhecimento é todo
este processo estão o processo é uma
equipa que está
traz médicos enfermeiros e auxiliares
toda a gente é um sentimento infinito de
aquecimento é um sentimento infinito de
aquecimento
isa não diria que sim do orgulho mas de
crescimento por poder estar presente
neste processo foi com meu filho podia
ter sido com outra pessoa qualquer
isto importa ressalvar é que isto de nós
conseguirmos isso vamos criar esta esta
dinâmica
eu dou aqui mas se um dia precisar
alguém vai dar a mim seria muito mais
fácil
este processo é muito mais humano também
porque eu acho que pensamos e agora no
tema do next tempo vim próximo passo
queremos chamar pra mim é um recomeço
atrás ou seja pensarmos que o que são
jogadores mais importantes é o valor
mais importante que ser amigo é ser
enfim o tema amor é uma coisa tão caro
[Música]
mas
[Aplausos]
hum hum
tá
[Música]